middle earth is filled to the brim with
all kinds of magical beings and
creatures and while many of them live
fairly short lives others can grow to be
very old indeed
of course nowhere is this more evident
than with the members of the fellowship
of the ring themselves peregrine tuke is
by far the youngest member of the
fellowship of the ring coming in
at a youthful 29 years old when the ring
is destroyed
this makes pippin extraordinarily young
even for a hobbit
hobbits tend to age slowly drawing out
their adolescent years right through
their 20s
in fact in the fellowship of the ring
this extended adolescence is defined as
the irresponsible 20s between childhood
and
coming of age at 33. in other words
pippin is so young that he still has
four years to go before he even comes of
age
according to the standards of his own
people so while he might be a little
young to go traipsing around the
continent
on life or death world-saving adventures
pippin ultimately makes the case for his
youthful presence in a number of ways
for one he indirectly helps the cause by
giving into temptation
and looking in the palantir preventing
gandalf from accidentally doing so
himself
which would have revealed the wizards
thoughts to sauron and meant disaster
for the free peoples
on top of that the young hobbit helps
convince the ants to attack isengard and
ultimately saves faramir from being
burned alive by his own father
heck in the books he even
single-handedly takes down a huge hill
troll chief in the final battle at the
black gate
young or not it's a pretty lucky thing
he's on the team
maria doc brandy buck is the second
youngest member of the fellowship
at 37 years old when the ring falls into
the fires of mount doom making him
nearly a decade older than his cousin
and best friend pippen while still young
for a hobbit mary demonstrates a
distinct level of maturity that his
younger compatriot tends to lack
for instance when pippin casually shrugs
off the repercussions of looking into
sauromon's seeing stone
it's mary who calls his friend out on
his flipped attitude
he sees the inherent danger that they're
facing and chastises pippin for
his foolishness even throwing in the jab
that his friend smokes too much
this wouldn't be the first time mary has
had pippin's back either
as he watches pippin race away with
gandalf on shadow facts mary points out
to aragorn that he's always been there
to get his friend out of trouble
i would get him into the worst sort of
trouble
but i was always there to get him out
and sure mary does spend most of his
time indulging in drink and stealing
fireworks but he does turn out to be
just as valuable in addition to the crew
as pippin
if it weren't for mary's help for
example the ants likely wouldn't have
attacked eisenguard
it's also mary's small act of bravery
that helps eowyn kill the witch king
once again vindicating his small yet
critical presence
in such an old and venerable fellowship
as far as hobbits go samwise gamji is
much closer to a proper adult but
a young one by the last days of the
third
age sam is 39 years old even at his
relatively young age
sam's temper mood and general demeanor
attack toward
the more mature side of things compare
him with his hobbit companions for
example
mary and pippin tend to be distracted by
the slightest
opportunity to eat drink smoke and
generally mess around
but sam has no problem prioritizing and
tending to his responsibilities
whether they consist of caring for the
bag end garden pursuing rose cotton
or helping his master travel across the
world to throw a ring into a volcano
that said sam does still have his
youthful moments
for instance early in the fellowship of
the ring he's informed that the hobbits
will be taking a shortcut across the
shire in order to avoid a run-in with
the black riders
predictably sam goes along with this
knowing it's his duty to follow his
master wherever he goes
inside however he has his own misgivings
due to a deep regret at the fact that
they won't get to pass by an inn on the
road that's particularly well known for
its excellent beer
[Music]
but for the most part sam is perfectly
capable of demonstrating wisdom and
endurance far
beyond his years he remains faithfully
by frodo's
side correctly predicts gollum's
treachery fends off sheila by himself
keeps his master focused and ultimately
carries him halfway up a mountain
so yeah go sam while he doesn't live to
see the ring destroyed boromir is 41
years old when he joins the fellowship
of the ring putting him just a tad older
than
sam boromir is a man of war through and
through
who in spite of his years still
possesses a decent amount of youthful
vigor
brave strong and daring the heir to the
steward of gondor displays equal parts
experience and energy throughout the
fellowship's early adventures
while he's most known by fans for his
betrayal and attack on frodo before that
point boromir had cultivated a stellar
military reputation and is widely known
as a fierce warrior a cunning captain
and a brave leader of men he's also
idolized by both the soldiers of gondor
and the riders of rohan
in fact even the recklessly brave eomer
describes him as a worthy man
adding that more like to the swift sons
of aorl than to the grave men of gondor
he seemed to me
and likely to prove a great captain of
his people when his time came
even after he falls to the lure of the
ring boromir is able to rally his spirit
and sacrifice himself in defense of his
younger companions
in the end however it's not enough and
boromir becomes the only member of the
fellowship to truly perish during the
war of the ring
frodo baggins has a full 10 years on
boromir making him 51 years old by the
end of his adventures
in fact he pretty much kicks things off
by leaving bag end the day after his
51st birthday
while this puts him squarely in the
middle of a hobbit's lifespan the truth
is the 51 year old ring bearer actually
has the body and demeanor of a 33 year
old when he sets out on his quest
frodo receives the ring from his cousin
bilbo during his 33rd birthday party
which happens to
exactly coincide with bilbo's 111th
birthday
from that day forward the hobbit doesn't
age a day
the magic of the ring prevents his body
from aging keeping him young
and attracting the envy of his rapidly
aging neighbors
so while frodo is technically older than
mary sam
and boromir in a certain sense he's
physically younger than all of them
this ends up bringing him the perfect
mix of youthful strength and middle-aged
wisdom that makes frodo the perfect
candidate for the job of carrying and
destroying the one ring
aragorn is practically unique among the
men of middle earth particularly during
the events of the lord of the rings and
this comes down to his noble bloodline
which can trace its lineage back to the
elves back in the very beginning of the
second age
aragorn's ancestor the half elf elros
chose to become a mortal man
while this decision made him mortal
elrose nevertheless lived to be an
impressive 500 years old
over time his descendants lived shorter
and shorter lives but they still tended
to age far slower than most other men
now in the movie version of the two
towers aragorn tells eowyn that he's 87
years old
you cannot be 80.
87. but it just so happens that
aragorn's birthday occurs in the same
month that the ring is destroyed
as a result aragorn has lived an
impressive 88 years by the end of the
third age this puts the ranger head and
shoulders over the younger members of
the company
he's almost twice as old as frodo and
he's triple pippin's age
but while he remains a steadfast warrior
aragorn's age
also makes him a particularly deft
leader of men
priming him for his role as the eventual
high king of gondor and arnor
in the end aragorn goes on to rule for
another 120 years
finally dying at the ripe old age of
210.
gimli tends to be the one to provide the
occasional dose of comic relief
especially in the movies and this might
sometimes make him seem like a fairly
young dwarf
and to be fair he is young by dwarvish
standards
in fact he's just 140 years old during
the war of the ring
for context when thorin oakenshield is
killed during the battle of five armies
he's nearly 200 years old
when balin falls in his attempt to
retake moria he's 231 years old
heck when dane ironfoot dies in battle
during the war of the ring
he's 250 years old and still swinging a
battle axe like it's nobody's business
suffice it to say that gimli is still in
his youth when he joins the fellowship
in fact in j.r.r tolkien's posthumously
published work
unfinished tales gimli points out that
he was around during the events of the
hobbit and wanted to join the quest of
araber to reclaim his people's lost home
and treasure
the only reason he didn't is that as he
explains
i was not allowed to go on the quest too
young they said
though at 62 i thought myself fit for
anything
fortunately by the time of the lord of
the rings he's more than doubled in age
making him the perfect dwarf to bring a
little muscle to the ranks of the nine
walkers
being an elf legolas is immortal as a
result his age means little to him and
apparently it meant little to tolkien
too
the author provides very little
backstory for the elven prince which is
kinda strange considering how important
legolas is
in the larger story with that said it's
possible to at least figure out enough
about the merkwood princeling to
understand that he's much
older than almost everyone else in the
fellowship
specifically there's a line spoken by
legolas in the two towers as he
aragorn gimli and gandalf approach
eteros and discuss
the history of the kingdom of men when
gandalf mentions the building of the
golden hall legolas points out
500 times have the red leaves fallen in
murkwood in my home since then
and but a little while does that seem to
us
in other words legolas life stretches
way back to before rohan was ever
founded
making him at least 500 years old and
likely much much older than that
gandalf is hands down the oldest member
of the fellowship of the ring for a
number of different reasons and
likely by a good margin too let's start
with his physical form
gandalf the wizard arrived in middle
earth roughly 2 000 years before the
ring was destroyed
now if this were his actual birth date
you might be able to make an argument
that legolas could well be older than
gandalf
but the truth is gandalf's time as an
old man in middle earth is just
one small part of a very long life this
is because gandalf is one of the mayar a
host of angelic spiritual beings that
serve the godlike valar in the undying
land
gandalf was only given his elderly body
when he was sent to middle earth to help
guide the free peoples in their war
against sauron
for millennia before that he existed as
the spirit oloran
and was more than likely around before
the creation of the universe itself
it might not come as much of a surprise
considering he's the wisest and most
powerful member of the fellowship but
it's true enough regardless
gandalf is the oldest member of the
company by a
long long way indeed check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you